do you think we did the right thing
moving here you're in your dream job
we're in this radical apartment how do
you think the rent is so cheap do you
yield from time to time members of a
deranged cult or a can enter in order to
commit self murder does the super Knight
go over this with you and you looked at
the apartment Reginald storsch
incited over two dozen innocent victims
to self murder he committed suicide in a
bathtub bathtub is magical and will
magically hold on to the afterglow for
all eternity more we learn about stores
I can see why these people follow him
I'm totally good with having a little
store in our lives he's a little more
blood and violence but that's no biggie
you know these poor souls worked so hard
to meet stores in the Eternity but they
really have trouble what's it like
they totally suck at suicide it's our
apartment
what's wrong with helping our visitors
with the Queens transition into eternity
it's weird how they all have some kind
of red dye on their lips now
[Music]
the beacons storsch was the lip and the
people came I know I did I know you know
you did this is our destiny
painless Oh Dave this actually hurts
quite a bit
you
you